some people claim that zakat on wealth
if above nisab has to be paid only once
in a lifetime if you have paid zakat on
a particular wealth or gold you don't
have to pay it again next year is there
a difference of opinion in this matter
alhamdulillah what salat wa salam ala
rasulillah viola leave aside regimen I'm
my bad I was billahi min
ash-shaytaan-i'r rajeem bismillah
r-rahman r-rahim
rubbish early Saturday westerly Embree
what Melissa I've got only as far as a
guy in the question is a different
opinion as far as a card should be paid
once in a lifetime or should be paid
every year in the past 1,400 years right
from the time of the sahabas did the
Salafist Halloween till late never has
there been any scholar any fokaha who
has ever said that the card should be
paid only once in lifetime you read the
Quran you read the hadith the things of
the Prophet never will you find any
hadith any chronic was any scholar that
has ever said there's a car should be
paid only once there's no difference of
opinion whatsoever lately just a few
years back this issue has come to the
picture and I was there in Chile a few
years back the same question was asked
to me originated from chinaís that's
South India where freshness and there
was a local person who had raised this
issue and there is ample of evidence
from the hadith that jihad should be
paid every year and there's no question
of different opinion and I don't know
how this controversy came up if you read
the hadith of Mosul asalaam it's
mentioned in son Abu Daoud or in the
mature vocal zakat hadith number one
five six eight the beloved prophet musa
alehsalaam said that if you have two
hundred drums and if you possess it for
a period of one year then you have to
pay five drums let me - enough percent
140th of it and there is no sucker
on gold if you have less than 20 dinars
no here it says that you have to pay
zakat if you possess it for one full
complete here there's no mention that I
figure once in lifetime it indicates
that if you pause this for two years
after be twice if you put it for three
other repeat thrice it's understood if
anyone says that it has to be given once
in lifetime there should be proof in the
Quran and the hadith which stated
clearly and there are various other
hadith which clarify this issue if you
read the hadith of son Abu Daoud or in
number two because Akkad hadith number
one 577 the beloved prophet musa
alehsalaam said that anyone who has
three signs has seen belief the one who
worship only allah subhanaw taala
who says there is no God worthy of
worship except allah subhan allah tala
and one who pay zakat on his property
agreeably every year here the statement
is clearly mentioned every year that
means a car should be paid every year so
there is no difference open it alright
so authentic hadith and furthermore
there are various references that can be
given that can easily disprove this
point that it should be paid only once
in the lifetime the hadeeth mentioned in
Sai Baba b1 b2 in the Kazakh hadeeth
number one for zero to you some people
argued that you know it's a car need not
be paid on life talk and etcetera
etcetera this hadith of seibu hari om
the matured in the bazooka hadith number
one four zero two it says that Hamas
Elohim said that animals of the life
stock the camels they will appear on the
day of resurrection in the healthiest
form and they have been in the world and
will go to the master to the owner and
if you have not paid the cart they will
tread them under the feet and the hadith
continues that the sheep they will
appear in the healthiest form that
they've been on this earth and if the
owner has not paid zakat they will but
them with the horn and will trample them
married off indicating that the wrath
should be given from the animals
further if you read the hadith of Abu
Bakr me live with him it's mentioned in
saber hari om number two in the back of
zakat hadith number one three nine nine
and hadith number one four zeros ago
there were some Arabs who did not want
to give zakat and they revolted so how
does that work I'm alive be with him he
said that he will wage a war against
these people
Tom Hartman live with him said that but
The Messenger of Allah said that those
who believe in Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
and don't worship anyone else and those
who say lie lie the la mohammed
rasoolullah we should not wage a war
against them so how about Kerman life
with him said that anyone who breaks the
law
he'll wage a war against them and anyone
differentiates between salah and zakat
that both a complicity he'll wage a war
against them and by allah he says that
anyone who used to give a sh e kid or a
lamb at the name of the Prophet and now
is it locked in to give or does not give
that was a shot which is trigger the
time of the Prophet he will wage a war
against them indicating that those
Assad's was given last year this year -
it has to be given and if they did not
give how's Abu Bakar my appeal with him
he would wage a war against them and how
the Omar Minaya president says that
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala had opened in
the heart of Abu Bakr and what he said
was right indicating that the heart has
to be knavery you furthermore they're
very hadith how's the cards used to be
connected and there the hadith if
measure inside Bukhari born in B - in
the bazooka hadith number one four five
four where a person says that you are
the pointer bottle of water will not be
the Tim took elixir cut and he said that
The Messenger of Allah Samantha said
house a car should be collected and he
goes on saying that if it's a camel if
the number is five then you're free one
sheep as a heart and the number keeps on
increasing and the Sirat
each one increasing if it's 40 sheep
when you have a flock of 40 sheep you're
shooting one
as a cut anywhere between the number of
40 to 120 that zakat is one chip if the
number of sheep between 120 and 200 two
sheep have to be given for zakat if it
is between 200 and 300 three sheep have
to be given and for every hundred extra
one sheep has to be given now when the
collector of zakat went to collect the
zakah they have to count the livestock
they have to count the head of the
cattle they now looked for how many new
cattle have you got how many new were
born they counted all the cattle
available there that means they even
took satire on the capital left repaid
earlier they didn't say okay this
already laughter you gave so I not count
that please give me the number that you
have purchased lately or the new kids
that have been born or they should look
out for any go to any sheep which is
less than one year old that was in the
case so this clearly proves that the car
has to be given every year and it should
be given as long as we possess the
wealth for a period of one year and if
the nisab is above the level then it
should pay every year and this idea that
it should be given once in a lifetime is
a new idea which is never heard before
it just came few years back it's unheard
of in the past 49 ideas so there's no
difference of opinion whatsoever
whichever group of folk aha whatever
they're all of them agree that fetching
feed every that clay is that up
hamdulillah